Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another edition
of YouTube Developers Live.
My name is Ikai
Lan, and today we're
going to be talking
about how to keep up
to date on the Java
API Client Library.
So those of you who have
been following the show
will know that we have
moved our samples away
from code.google.com
to github.com.
So why don't we go ahead
and switch to my computer.
Now, if you're going to
code.google.com/p/youtube-api-samples,
hopefully you're seeing
a warning that says hey,
we've moved to GitHub.
Check us out.
And this is what some of our
GitHub samples look like.
Right here, that's
a Java sample.
This is the right page
you should be looking at.
So if we click through
to the Java sample,
one thing that you usually want
to keep up to date-- if you
want to keep up to
date with new APIs--
is the version of the Java
API client that you're using.
So one way you can do this
is by looking in Maven
and looking at palm.xml.
And I'm going to blow
this up real quick.
You'll see that there's a
YouTube version and a YouTube
Analytics version.
And this is a really
good way to make sure
that you download code
that will definitely work,
is by copying the samples.
But what if we're not always
keeping the samples up to date?
What if we release a new
API-- and the samples,
they might lag a few days, but
you need that API right away--
how do you know what the newest
version of the API client
library is?
Well, it's not on the
Java Code Samples page,
but there's a page we have
on developers.google.com
for the API client libraries.
This is the API
Client Library Home.
And you can get here by going to
developers.google.com/API-client-library.
And again, you can
always search for this
in your favorite
search engine and it'll
take you to this page.
And what you want to do is you
want to click through to Java,
Supported Google APIs-- let's
scroll all the way down--
and you'll see that there's the
YouTube Analytics API, as well
as the Data API.
So I'm going to go ahead
and open these in a new tab.
OK, so I'm on the Data
API Client for Java.
I'm going to scroll down and
you can download the client
library, but
usually the best way
is probably to use a build
system like Maven or Gradle
because there's
lots of dependencies
that the library depends on.
So click on the
Maven tab, and you'll
see what the Palm configuration
is, so palm.xml configurations.
Now we look here,
it's rev79-1-17-0.
Good, our sample's
up to date on that.
Now let's just make sure our
Analytics API sample's also
up to date.
Click on Maven.
So rev24.1.17.
24.1.17.
Good.
So this means that
all of our samples
are currently up to date.
And again, as you're
watching the show,
there's probably going to be a
newer version of the API client
libraries out.
Don't copy these exact numbers.
Instead, you should go to
developers.google.com/API-client-libraries/java
and this will be the right
place to look for what the most
current version is.
And this is only
something you have
to do if you're using a
statically-typed language
such as Java.
If you're using a language
such as Python or Ruby,
you don't need to do this.
The Python library automatically
generates the API document.
It automatically
generates the methods
that you use to make API calls.
So you won't need to
keep as up to date,
but do check periodically
for major releases.
Well, that's all I have
for you guys today.
Thank you for tuning in
for this very short show.
Just wanted to share
some tricks with you
for all the other fellow
Java developers out there.
All right, take care
and have a great day.